matt gorley good to see you hi
uh sonia mosses how are you hello how
are your little gentlemen doing they're
very good i'd still sing them the little
gentlemen song they like it a lot how's
that go my little gentlemen it's when i
wipe their mouths
the only way they'll be cool that's a
song no i little gentlemen
my little gentleman
i dab your little face okay all right
let's dance
and they like that
yeah i think i could sing anything and
they'll be like
wow a true mother's love for her
children
gourley was lovely seeing your daughter
the other day you know i want to get the
word out that we uh recorded some summer
s'mores and we were over at your house
yeah and uh i got to meet your daughter
which was really nice you're talking
about bill squishman
what that's her nickname
what
her full nickname is bill squishman
founder squishman enterprises co-founder
siegel squishman dynamics quality
through
cuteness cute
that's so sweet why bill squishman what
kind of name is that for take a look at
her she just looks like a 50s
businessman
your daughter does kind of look like uh
eisenhower era at
yeah i'm lost on my own podcast i don't
i don't know what we're talking about
now
our family our families oh yeah you had
nicknames for nevin beckett i'm sure
that were weird and child one child too
no you come into a room and you call
people chopper and stuff like oh i love
that i love so why can't you wrap your
head around this no bill just threw me a
little bit okay uh that you switched
genders you know but i shouldn't because
i know that everyone's gender fluid
modern times modern times so your
daughter is bill squishman head of
squishman enterprise founder
founder okay
and head then head of title on the
business card nice
uh what a lovely story you'll have for
her one day where'd you call me papa
little snuckums snackums we called you
bill squishman founder of squishman
enterprises
co-founder siegel squishman dynamics
quality through cuteness how do you feel
in your new role as father do you think
you're a good dad or you i don't know if
i'm a good dad but i have never been
happier in my life i am crazy about this
it is insane i love it so it took me
years to start to understand this whole
affection for children thing
eliza kept saying get in there and try
one more time just spend more time with
them i'm like i don't know
what does this have to do with my career
oh yeah i don't see how this helps me
i am i look at her and go you can take
me away from my career i love you so
much oh that's sweet yeah you say that
but you don't mean it once you're around
them for a while like more than an hour
that's when you want out
i don't know
you're you're a cold
uh just
withered dead tree on a hilltop you know
you've got no no emotion man you need to
you're right you need to
warm up
yeah all right that's good advice yeah
that's good advice i'm going to do that
i'm going to change completely i
obviously it's a it's a it's a joke i
love my children i've seen you interact
with your kids and you're very loving
tender father i fight my son a lot you
guys do wrestle i wrestle everybody i
love physical confrontation um and i
think it's a good way to get closer to
people is to fight them you've never
fought me no no i haven't i'm worried
about you
one good punch from me and you might
just fall apart oh really what's true
you know look at me i'm a big masculine
man oh well i was gonna say i never
side with him but you do seem
a little not brittle what's the word i'm
like fragile excuse me you do i mean to
be fair you look like you're made of
marzipan and you're a delicious treat
for the holidays but excuse me but i do
think that i was in the theater
department i'm sure you were okay i'm
sure you were right i have um i have a
master's degree in theater so
let's have some respect here i think in
a cartoon if i punched you really hard
you'd explode into a bunch of pieces and
then they would all fall down and you'd
be this nice arrangement of hummel
figurines that would fall down and
assemble themselves you think i'm
fragile yeah i still own all my legos
okay no but you know what i mean he is
i'm a guy who can take a punch and give
a punch no i'm a man's man through and
through an anchor tattoo on my bicep arm
wrestle is that what this is are you arm
wrestle doesn't prove anything i'm just
saying oh yeah dodge
matt matt nice dog if i needed to i
would i could claw through your chest to
get through you instantly
um but i mean i might just like right
when you do that i'll bust into a
shakespeare monologue what are you gonna
do then i don't know
so i would love to the two of you
fighting the picture i have in my head
is just this well it's very quick it's
very quick
it's a slap fight
i think slap fighting is like a lot of
this far away
i slap kick and bite if i have to but i
get the job done that's my motto
yeah
well i'm sorry i called you fragile but
yeah i mean that means that you're not
like a a fighter yeah no i'm not a
fighter that's a compliment i'm glad to
do this podcast we found someone to sit
across from me who makes me feel like a
tough guy oh that's what we essentially
that's what we essentially did i feel
like ernest borgnine over here
i
feel like no i feel like i feel like a
big bruiser um really let me just take a
drink
all right well should we get into the
show yeah please you better before i get
angry you wouldn't like me when i'm
angry
and you're it's it's called cranky you
know [ __ ] me you wouldn't like me you
wouldn't like me when i get fussy it's
not the same it's not the same you
wouldn't like me don't make me fussy you
wouldn't like me fussy